Dark patterns are features of interface
design,
crafted to trick users into doing things
that they might not want to do,
but which benefit the business in
question,
here's an example.
Have you ever tried to delete your
Amazon account?
Here's the Amazon homepage.
What's the first thing you might think
to do?
The obvious place to look is the account
drop down here.
Once you're in here,
you look around.
It's a lot of information,
but if I'm interested in deleting my
account,
I think that your account is probably a
good place to go.
Once I'm on this page,
there's a lot more information,
payment options,
logging insecurity,
and a bunch of stuff down here.
Unfortunately,
you could click every link on your
account page,
but none would deliver you to a place
where you could actually delete it
because it's not here.
In order to actually delete your Amazon
account,
you have to go all the way down to the
bottom of the page and under.
Let us help you click help.
Once you're in here,
you have to navigate to need more help
because you know,
putting it on this page would just be
too easy.
Then click contact us.
This is where it starts to get
ridiculous and it's still nowhere to be
seen,
but of the four options on the top of
that,
you want help with click prime or
something else.
You want this something else in this.
Tell us more about your issue dropdown.
There's still nothing that suggests
account deletion.
You just have to know to click login and
security,
and then in a second dropdown,
there it is the magic button.
Close my account,
except in order to actually do that,
you have to have a chat conversation
with an Amazon associate who's going to
tell you all the reasons I count.
Deletion is a bad idea.
See,
you can't delete the account yourself.
They have to do it for you.
This is a dark pattern,
a crappy user experience that
intentionally makes it difficult,
almost impossible without help to do
something that hurts Amazon ux
specialists.
Harry brignull categorizes this specific
kind of dark pattern as a roach motel,
a design that makes it very easy for you
to get into a situation,
but very hard to get out.
Brignull is actually the one who coined
the term dark pattern in 2010,
and he's been cataloging and lecturing
about the issue ever since.
Many of these dark patterns we're all
familiar with and only have to search my
email for a few seconds to find one.
For example,
here,
I'm getting spam emails from
architectural digest.
I scroll down and look at that.
This is a mess,
but it's a mess on purpose.
The unsubscribe link is here,
but it's devilishly hard to see.
That's because it's the same font and
virtually the same color as the rest of
the fine print.
Here's another dark pattern that uses
color to misdirect over at the user
testing blog.
Jennifer Jerome points out that the
mobile game two dots carries you through
the experience by offering green
buttons,
a green button to start the game,
a green button to pick a level of green
button to start the level and three
green buttons to continue to the next
level and so,
but once you lose a level,
the color scheme changes.
The first screen button you see leads,
you right an in app purchase while the
continue button is just a little x that
blends into the larger element.
I wonder how many people clicked by
moves reflexively as a Pedalo vion
response.
Now,
to be fair,
this is a pretty benign dark pattern,
but it shows how companies can use
something as simple as color to trick
you into doing what they want.
On the more egregious end of the
spectrum,
you have stuff like this banner ad for
chat most which is made to look like it
has a speck of dust on it,
causing people to brush it away and
accidentally clicked the link.
Or you have sites like booking.com
where they do everything in their power
to increase the urgency of a purchase
going so far as to alert you in big red
notifications of the hotel rooms that
you just missed you better book.
Now you don't want to be left behind
again,
do you every once in a while a company
goes a little too far and actually
breaks the law.
Remember when you used to get spammed
with all those linkedin invites from
friends?
Well,
that was because of a confusing dark
pattern on there.
Add contacts page which allowed linkedin
to scoop up people's email contacts and
send them messages repeatedly without
their consent and a comprehensive blog
post stand.
Schlosser showed how linkedin tried to
trick users eat times and their sign up
and onboarding procedures into
surrendering their email contacts.
Unfortunately for Linkedin,
this proved to be a step too far.
Users filed a legal challenge claiming
that sending multiple unwarranted emails
hurt their professional reputation.
Linkedin settled the dispute for $13
million dollars,
which came out in the end to about $10
per user.
It's rare for dark patterns to face
consequences like these mostly they stay
just on the right side of the law,
understanding that it's hard to
legislate around the psychological
tricks of Ux design.
Everything on the Internet is fighting
for your attention,
but there's a difference between those
who are taking the time to build trust
and loyalty and the special offer you
clicked which actually enrolled you in a
monthly subscription or the social
network,
that dark pattern you until letting it
cell data that you didn't even know it
had.
Some of the responsibility is on us,
but some is on design too and it's not
the fault of the designers.
They're just doing what they're tasked
to do.
Knowing full well that if they don't,
others will,
as bricknell says,
our best defense against the dark
patterns is to be aware of them and
shame the companies who utilize them.
Design is what mediates our interaction
with the Internet.
It's the language we read it in.
It's not too much to ask that that
language be comprehensible and
hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
This episode is brought to you by Nord.
VPN now if you care like I do a lot
about your privacy and security online,
you should absolutely be using a vpn or
a virtual private network to keep your
data safe by allowing you to connect to
stuff remotely so that prying eyes can't
see your ip address and private
information.
Personally,
I've had a few hacking scare,
so vpns really helped ease my mind when
I'm online and Nord.
VPN is the best out there.
Bar none.
If you're watching this right now,
you can get 77 percent off a three year
plan by visiting Nord Vpn Dot com slash
nerd writer or using the Promo Code
nerdwriter at checkout.
I've shopped around in this space and
use a few vpns,
nor vpn is definitely my favorite by a
mile.
Not only does it have military grade
encryption and a thousand servers in 61
countries,
you can run it simultaneously and up to
six devices,
which means you can run it on your
computers and your phone so that when
you're accessing Wifi and a cafe,
which I do a lot,
or a restaurant or an airport,
you know you'll be safe and again,
nor vpn is offering my viewers.
Seventy seven percent off,
three year plans.
Just go to www dot nord,
vpn.com/nerd
writer,
or click the link in the description
below to sign up and start protecting
yourself.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.